hi there steve kaufman here i want to do
a video today about vocabulary
frequency lists
the lexical approach a lot of things
that have to do with
vocabulary and language learning it's
something i've talked about before so i
might be repeating myself
but i put a post on my blog the linguist
on language blog
and there i posted a reference to a
review that i came across of michael
lewis's uh the lexical approach
which is an often quoted source and one
of my followers here or my readers or
listeners at my youtube channel in fact
was the one who brought the book to my
attention i went searching on the
internet
and i found this
summary of the book michael lewis
points out that vocabulary
is more important than grammar
language is about words
it's not about some
analytical
sort of uh
theory it's not a machine
that can be analyzed it's more of a of a
naturally growing organism
uh like a plant or a tree that needs to
be fed nourishment which is
which is input which is uh basically
words i guess that causes the the plant
to grow
uh so lots of interesting stuff in
michael lewis's book the lexical
approach i recommend you read you go to
that link that i put in my blog
i might be able to put the link here in
the comment section to this video
uh i don't know if if michael lewis was
the first person to make reference to
the fact that we learn languages we
learn these chunks of languages these
collocations which is another
word that's used
where
you know the native speaker will
naturally use certain words with certain
other words
the learner doesn't know that those
words belong together that's something
that we need to learn
certainly i agree with that
um
but i do have a slightly different take
on it
michael lewis of course because he's
trying to instruct teachers on how to
teach the language
has a number of exercises or
drills that can be used
to help
learners become aware of these
uh of these uh
collocations or chunks
and uh obviously i've often said too
that language learning is about becoming
aware it's about our attitude it's about
how much time we spend and it's about
becoming aware so these exercises are
undoubtedly a good thing i don't like to
do exercises so when i see exercise i
immediately sort of pull away
and
what i have found with regard to phrases
and collocations and chunks is the
following and so this might be different
from other people's experience but this
has certainly been my experience that as
i'm getting going in the language i'm
actually much more interested in words
than in phrases and if someone tells me
this is a common phrase
i may or may not i mean
i would say i don't believe them but i
can't fit that into any context because
i don't have enough experience with the
language now there are some examples
like germappel my name is but in fact i
call myself or menya zavut in russian
you know uh they call me uh and so those
are phrases that you pick up very early
but but beyond that there's sort of many
many many uh
uh sort of
collocations if you want that none comes
to mind right now uh you know flaming
uh hot or flaming red coals or
uh
things like that words that we would
normally use together if i see them i
won't remember them and and so that i
find that my reaction to learning these
phrases and collocations is much the
same as the way i deal with grammar yeah
you can give it to me now when i'm
getting started it won't register very
much
on the other hand after significant
exposure to the language
then i can go back in and learn these
collocations
because
you know
because my initial motivation is to
learn is to understand the language to
be able to read it to be able to
understand it when i hear it it's always
the missing word that causes trouble for
me if i know four words
and i can't put the phrase together in
terms of meaning
and so the meaning remains more or less
vague to me i just move on it doesn't
bother me i
know that one day those words will
somehow make sense right now the
structure seems
awkward and strange so i can't really
figure out what they're saying but i
know what the individual words mean
and occasionally i've got the wrong
meaning from the dictionary so it's even
more confused none of that bothers me uh
what i have found now in my check is
that after
you know a little over two months you
know i can actually there's i don't have
that many words in the dictionary that
in the sort of the newspaper rather that
i don't understand i can read the
newspaper if i hear a radio program from
radio praha i don't understand it very
well but if i read it i understand a lot
of it and of course if i read it with
link open or on my ipad or on my
computer i understand it eighty percent
there's still some confusing terms of
phrase that that leave me a bit
you know uh in the lurch but it doesn't
bother me so
my initial motivation is to get as many
words as possible and that's where i
have trouble with the graded reader
approach a lot of experts in in uh sort
of vocabulary learning who are in favor
of a lot of input but who also favor
other exercises to help with vocabulary
recommend reading material where you
have 98
known words that this is where you get
the greatest likelihood of picking up
incidental vocabulary because you have
so much
surrounding you know there's so much
context that you understand that you can
make out the meaning of the missing
words um you know i've been at check for
two months and a bit if i had been
always looking for content that had 98
known words i would be i would have
progressed very very slowly as it is now
i think i know seven eight nine thousand
words in check i've been at it for a
little over two months uh link tells me
i know
fifteen thousand but i don't believe
that on the other hand when i open up a
new item that i bring in literature now
i'm bringing in carol chapek
whatever
most of the words are are white they're
supposedly known and very few of those
white words do i have to look up
so i must know a lot of words
lots eight ten thousand i don't know
some large number that i know
and the other words that are showing up
in yellow uh i'm reminded that i've
looked them up before and though so
those are words that i'm getting to know
so i've got a lot of words and if i had
relied on um
you know graded readers
and uh
tried to stay at that 98 comfort zone i
would not have a lot of words and and
the fact that i can't use my check i
can't speak
and maybe if i had stayed with very
simple content that i would be closer to
speaking
but i don't want to speak and then not
understand the avalanche of stuff that
comes back to me from a native speaker i
want to be able to speak
when i understand what the speaker is
likely to say to me and so the fact that
i'm
not able to say much now and check
doesn't really bother me i'm far more
determined to build up my vocabulary and
i think the big change now is that
compared to 20 years ago you know
there's so much text available with
audio so you can listen listen listen
read
listen read
there are these online dictionaries
there are systems like link and others
that help you i can get this stuff up on
my ipad and i read it and if i know i
can't remember the word i just you know
tap it on the screen touch touch touch
up come the words and i read through it
i can even listen to it read it and so
and i'm enjoying it because it's more
interesting to work your way through
this kind of interesting material rather
than uh you know staying with the uh
with the old
collocations
uh but you know just to show you how
uh oh i was gonna say so i have this
book here
uh second language vocabulary
acquisition which i i have a lot of
books on the whole subject of language
learning people think that i just ignore
what everybody has to say and just you
know prattle on with my own views no no
i have my experience and i also read
what other people have to say
and so there are a number of things
recommended for vocabulary learning one
of them is the use of mnemonics
in other words special things to help
you remember
and so here here are some examples from
this person jan holstein he says an
english learner of german trying to
remember the meaning of raupe
caterpillar could associate rape with
the english word robe or
an english learner of french trying to
learn paul
peacock could remember the word pawn
or
trying to learn the french word sup
valve might think of the word soup or
the french word blanca stretcher might
remember the english word branch uh
you know
and i'm saying to myself
uh i am not the slightest bit interested
it'll be a long while before i need the
word caterpillar
peacock
valve stretcher so you know anyway i
just mentioned that as a as a as an
aside i i think you know
80 what do they say 2 000 words account
for 80 of all content
why do you need
um
what do you call it graded readers
anything you read 80 of the words are
going to be your basic words so they're
truly important words you're going to
get lots of exposure to them
learning the other words the rarer
less common words but which are the key
words for the meaning of what you're
reading now there you need a different
strategy and a very good strategy is to
stay with one writer or one sort of area
of subject matter for periods of time so
that you get more frequent exposure to
them but on the other hand within link
because anything that i have ever looked
up is now highlighted for me in yellow
and come across it again i just touch it
and there it is so so i'm actually
reviewing it in context every time i
come across it now granted that doesn't
help me
that doesn't help me when i read a book
and so i do also find myself when
reading a book that i will
i will save a lot of these words that
i've uh underlined while reading and
i'll bring them into link so that they
will be highlighted when i'm reading uh
you know on the computer on my on my
ipad so
just some some thoughts on the whole
question of vocabulary acquisition
uh
and you know collocations and so forth
uh yeah we have to get used to how words
are naturally used by the native speaker
we have to increase increase our
awareness of that it's something that i
tend to do after having accumulated
quite a few words i find that i'm
starting to do it now more in check so
in fact what i'll often do in in link is
i'll go through and uh quick link
the blue words in other words the words
that uh that i don't know and now i go
back to the standard view so now i'm
clean of all the blue words
and then i go through and i just link up
some key phrases that i see in there and
so that the blue words are not in the
way so i do it sort of a two pass system
especially now that i'm more intent on
on going after some of these phrases
some of which are in fact collocations
so they're a bit of a ramble on the
subject of vocabulary which as i've said
many times to me is the absolute key to
language learning and if you acquire
those words through massive listening
and reading
then you won't forget in other words
first of all by doing that you are
acquiring the language because you're
having to listen to it and read it and
the brain is starting to figure it out
and it'll be a lot less difficult to
forget so
vocabulary input are still the buzzwords
and when i get a chance to speak i'm
going to speak and i i'm quite confident
that in
six months or whenever that time is when
i say okay now i really want to go after
speaking
the
it'll it'll come but in the meantime i
don't worry about the fact that i'm
quite inept if somebody were to try to
speak to me in check i would stumble
pretty badly
so
thank you for listening bye for now